[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about
meditation talking about creativity
talking about enlightened leadership we
have Dada naba Neel Ananda joining us on
the show hello thank you so much Ellen
I'm super pumped to have you
I love Thank You Ronnie for introducing
us very grateful for you the monk dude
is Dada's what do you call nickname it's
my brand your brand is his brand the
monk dude it's such a good brand it's
it's it sticks you know it's a musician
friend of mine came up with it it's it's
a great brand I love it I love it for
those that don't know Dada's background
40 years as a meditation instructor for
zero older than a lot of people watching
a yog among ordained in India in 1979
born in New Zealand as where is born
first also author keynote speaker at
Apple Google Facebook all these
prominent Bay Area firms also an
award-winning musician started playing
piano when he was how old four and then
composing when he was 11 yes yeah that's
so cool that's so cool and some and then
we have Donna's guitar here as well so
we will have some some nice special
music throughout which we're very
excited for all right and and for those
that want to know more on the background
on Dada he has a great TEDx talk as well
that you can find online for at the
upper east side is where that was
happening TEDx of every side so go and
check that out all right big history
perspective on civilization we love
starting here
so we find ourselves as stewards of
Earth now what is your synthesis on the
state of humanity okay so I'm not going
to talk about sapiens because
everybody's talking about it and
probably all the clever things have been
said already but I'm just I'm just
rereading it but I'll give you a
perspective you you might not have come
across so there's this idea in the
tradition of yoga of Gyana yoga or the
yoga of wisdom karma yoga the yoga of
action and service and bhakti yoga the
yoga of devotion and love and I realized
I've known this for a long time because
I've been doing this of my life but only
recently I realized that it's like that
those different qualities of wisdom love
and what we do with creating things with
our hands reflect our bodies so yeah
well we literally create stuff with our
hands were built civilization with our
hands the opposable thumb was one of the
three great differentiators from other
species the second of course is the mind
the brain so and hopefully we develop
wisdom through our brain so that's Gyana
yoga so Karma Yoga is the yoga of action
and creativity and work and service this
is represented by the hands Gianna yoga
the yoga wisdom is represented by the
mind and bhakti yoga is represented by
the heart and that's the other great
enabler because without community human
beings simply couldn't literally
couldn't survive because we take 15
years to mature and you know we're very
unusual amongst primates or mammals of
any kind to have such an extended
childhood and of course it's got a lot
to do with our brain so that would be
impossible to raise human children
without community if we didn't love one
another so this my the theme that I kind
of think binds a tire sort of sums up
humanity and actually can be used as a
lens through which to sort of to give
you a fresh perspective on human history
and the way that we've come to dominate
the planet
is that yeah we have these faculties
that have enabled us to be you know
smart maybe wise creative maybe in a
good way but maybe not and to feel love
and affection again if we limit it it's
a problem but if we express that feeling
of love and connection for everybody
then with if we use these three
faculties the way that they could be
used we can create a civilization worthy
of spreading to the Stars mmm okay let's
let's unpack those three are so good
okay the hands the brain the heart hands
head and hands head and heart and those
three have given us everything that that
we have and we have we find ourselves
now with such ubiquity in so many of the
daily necessities that we need to
survive I want to ask you this question
we're very grateful for the hundred
billion plus humans that built this
civilization
the seed I like using this metaphor I'm
curious what your thoughts are about it
that you you indicated this trajectory
this potential of really strong
compassion love tuning in word of trust
all of us working together and this
other trajectory which is kind of where
we're at now in some ways where we the
seeds of each human as they're being
birthed into the world didn't
necessarily get the right nutrients that
were needed and you indicated this as
well and you're in the section that you
talked about the in our infancy how how
much we need community how much we need
that love and compassion from from a
parent or relationship and a community
relationship so how much of that seed
metaphor around things do you do you
think about when it comes to giving them
the right nutrients in order to make
sure we can get to that trust and that
love and compassionate long-term
I will it's obviously key yes so yeah a
seed what does a seed it's represent
potential right that's a genetic code
and and and and and with an enormous
history but it can only sprout with the
right environment and you know we've
talked about you know how what makes you
what you are it's a mixture of nature
and nurture and the mix is debatable but
that's not the point
we can our potential can only flourish
if we're in the right environment and
there of course starts with even before
birth you know I think it's so important
what kind of environment a mother is in
you doing your station yes in the
environment outside their mother the
social fabric yeah yeah what what what
what in what moods
how are people treating her is she being
treated especially because she's
bringing a child into the world it's so
important what kind of music is she
listening to of course what kind of food
is cheating but it's not in the whole
emotional social physical environment
that the child grows in in the womb and
then beyond is tremendously important
that's what you know psychologists of
course will tell you the first five
years a critical for your emotional
makeup I know that my grandmother helped
to raise me and played a huge role in my
emotional giving me and emotional
stability that Amy my brother's didn't
have that they didn't have the same
opportunity because she was in England
when they were born I was the last she
came to New Zealand so yeah she needs
yeah a nurturing environment and you
have you know your song when I close my
eyes yeah is a direct relationship to
this hands heart and mind yeah it's kind
of philosophy put to music if that
sounds at all interest
I love with music sounds like the best
music with philosophy well yeah I know
you love philosophy and I do too but not
everybody does but everybody loves music
so I tried
feed the the you know something that we
ancient with them to a larger number of
people with some you know sound yes yes
some decoration and what's missing it so
this is a song about yeah the hands and
the hit and the hot and what what we can
be
[Music]
with my hand I'll build a spaceship in
case we run out of room like a wizard
who helps everybody's dreams come true
with my hands I only wanted to good
wouldn't you do that if you
liquor with my head I'll write a song
about saving the world every river every
robot every boy every girl singing
wisdom is the one missing thing what I
feel what I think when I
[Music]
No
[Music]
when I close my eyes I
[Music]
No
[Music]
who I be with my heart I'll tell your
sadness into unicorns and rainbows with
more colors and roses with the thorns
with our hearts we travel so far
together we start wet
[Music]
why
[Music]
I
who
[Music]
with our hearts we can travel too far
together we came from the stars
mic
where the house we travel so far
together we stop
ah such a good owner didn't philosophy
book right beautiful so good that was
written with a friend I must say with
Josh Friedman wonderful
singer-songwriter friend of mine is that
the one that helped you at the Munk dude
no Josh Josh Friedman listen los altos
yeah Josh Freeman Friedman he owes Chuck
maybe Josh is someone we should also
have he's a great musician and he sings
beautiful he makes amazing
very funny music for children oh cool
yeah he's such a colorful character
he'll be great on your show
love it love it please and that and the
fact that you guys wrote Cole it was a
co-wrote yaker Oak great we've written a
number of songs to get I love it
he has to pay background first though
great so this this process of kind of I
love what you just showed us there it's
you take what's your understanding of a
powerful way of seeing the world
that we can close our eyes we can have
our hearts open wide that we can
understand who we're meant to be that
taking these words making them into
music and delivering that through it as
a medium is gorgeous well but music is
the language of emotion right you can
listen to an instrumental piece if I
played just the guitar part without the
words it'll create a feeling and if I
play it to you here in San Francisco or
if I play it to somebody in Taiwan or
some in Kenya it's going to communicate
the same feeling they will it'll induce
the same feeling even though there's no
words that's right you know when they
translate a film they translate the
words but they don't change the music
because you know musics not just a
language of emotion it's a universal
language because it resonates with our
nervous system sound resonates with our
nervous system resonates with our
chakras if you believe in that stuff and
induces particular emotions and it's
common it's it's it's a special kind of
language and so I was lucky enough to be
have been you know attracted to it and I
got opportunities when I was young to
develop that and so I thought well this
isn't English is my only spoken language
almost everybody I know it speaks
another language so I feel kind of
stupid but I then I have this excuse I
said okay musics my second language so
leave me alone now that I'm curious what
is your target emotion to deliver
Universal love Universal is such a thing
but yes really a feeling of love without
limits yes we were talking earlier about
peak experiences on stage before you
know anything and we were talking about
you know performance and you know you've
been on stage ah being on stage and and
it's kind of neat having 10,000 people
or thinking you're cool
hopefully this you mess up and if people
get you know performance get high from
it because you know Mick Jagger famously
said that he would give up playing rock
and roll when he was thirty that was
more than 40 years ago and he's still
playing because he's he doesn't have a
higher experience in his life I don't
think or at least that's like a peak
experience for for performers and it's
very addictive and I've had a little
taste of that I had my 15 minutes of
fame as promised by Andy Warhol or ago
and back then it was back in 1992 and
but what I understood from it is okay
this is nice but actually what I can
experience when I really connect to the
core of myself is much much deeper and
much more fulfilling and more meaningful
and so yeah it's when I close my eyes
that I really that's when I experienced
my peak experiences
the culture and social fabric around us
needs to help catalyze the closing of
the ice more often and that makes it
easier for us to understand who we are
that makes it easier for us to get to
that limitless love that universal love
and we've kind of created a culture
where in many ways there are some old we
can call it kind of like a little bit
archaic lines of code of especially
capitalism that cause us to climb on top
of each other shoulders run around
relentlessly attempting to climb up
hierarchies of power and influence well
I don't think we we co-created that and
we just allowed ourselves to be to
follow that don't ever disregard the
dark villain among us there's there's a
underlying force that's never gonna
reveal itself
they cannot enslave us unless we allow
them
I'm saying we all right Ron mentioned it
so we must then ask is there what is it
what are your thoughts on the the dark
villain among us that will never reveal
itself well it's it there is us we
talked about seeds earlier it's there in
seed form and inside every of every one
of us but some people through a mixture
of nature nurture but either what we'd
say in yoga there's sort of also their
karmic momentum mm-hmm have become
dominated allowed or their their dark
side has come to dominate them and we
see this possibility reflected and all
the myths of you know Joseph Campbell's
studies so it talks about you know
that's just how you or I could have been
if our lives had followed a different
trajectory or you know we all have the
potential
it's important to remember that the
other way I think you all have the
potential yeah absolutely to me the
prison camp guard at Auschwitz exactly
it's part of being human we can be you
know saints or sinners as the Irish
would I would say Irish would say every
human every human has the passports
please allow me to introduce myself
it's like you're speaking of Mick Jagger
and all and and the great mythologies
and and sort of spiritual scriptures
they warn us about this again and again
and it's all about this struggle between
within this inner struggle yes between
the desire for power yeah and the power
of love and the power of God and
identify the quote when the power of
love overcomes the love of power then we
will know peace yes okay Jimi Hendrix
its Jimi Hendrix I thought it was both
maybe maybe both maybe Hendrix only yeah
maybe yeah both one many Hendrix
whatever it is yeah anyway that's like
someone just told me like yesterday or
something he's like Allen coin Earl real
estate I'm like I did not coin anything
I don't take any associations to coining
anything and I bear I'm just a human
visiting earth and I barely even
associate myself as a human in the first
is so so interesting yes and the power
of love overcoming the love of power and
all of us having via we both got with
look you better take you up in a little
taste of power I'm sure in in certain
ways yeah all right I don't know if you
have enough but anyway I have I mean in
an organization and it's has a certain
allure and it I'm lucky enough that it
doesn't attract me that much but some
people find it very attractive and it is
it does tend to be very corrupting as
the famous misquote you know
the misquote is absolute power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
the original quote is power tends to
corrupt and your absolute power tends to
corrupt absolutely critical difference
yeah the the TENS is the removal of the
binary and that's really important
because you can put it on a probability
curve for example there are politicians
or people in power in corporate settings
wherever you are around the world where
they have they have a little bit of a
lobbyist money slid across a table but
they can ethic they can hold their
ethics and their morals first and say
that no no and that is a very
interesting thing to take into account
is maybe that is the future of our world
is that moral guiding principle that
ethical guiding principle being first
and foremost ok there there was a you
know let's let's let's come back a
little bit as you speak on the seed and
the seeds ability to add something
you're a proponent of meditating twice a
day and closing eyes is on a
neurological side of things it's
removing the stimuli that you are taking
in from the eyes yeah and that's giving
you more peace is giving you more calm
that's giving you less of that
processing and then you can hear things
a little better and then you can maybe
hear your heart or hear your gut you
know hear your body functions and maybe
you can then quiet your mind when your
thoughts are starting to run you around
to everything you got to do and what
happens well you also have that great in
stein quote as well about the moments of
these Eureka moments coming in the
moments of silence I experience them all
the time and I've been a huge advocate
now of just taking this thing
keeping it off keep it off it's so
interesting keeping it off yeah that's
great yeah this is the late the new
addiction is pretty soon yeah and it's
it's all externalizing so the idea of
one of the key things in meditation is
closing your eyes and withdrawing your
attention from the external world and
focusing it inward okay
so because we're especially in our
modern environment we're in a world
where this so many attractions and
entertainments and you know we can watch
just thousand different movies for
almost free and it's endless distraction
from ourselves or ourselves so it's so
important it's even more important now
that we've created this secondary world
mmm so already the world was distracting
mm-hmm before electronics mmm now we've
created a second layer of distraction
through these windows of phones and
screens and you know sound that there as
well of course so that's like another
level of removal from the self so we
have to make an extra effort to withdraw
as you're doing you know switching off
your phone is an active withdrawal from
distraction it's great meditation itself
is you know part of it is withdrawing
your mind from the world and focusing
inward and then the next step is okay
focus on what so a lot of first steps in
meditation that will people talk about
is okay I'll begin by focusing on
something very simple and very central
to my being and they'll often start with
the breath because that's something we
don't think about much but it's we do it
all day and if we didn't we wouldn't be
here so that's an import a good starting
point I like to take people past that
pretty quickly to focusing on the source
of consciousness they're the the sense
of exists
and the reason I like to focus on that
and this is not my idea because this is
based on you know all yogic teachings
and insights the reason I like to I
think it's good great to focus on this
sense of existence is because that is
it's really the only thing we have in
common
mmm so what are the three of us have in
common where bodies are complete for
art's so we are each have a heart and we
have a physical heart okay that they're
separate they're physically separate oh
sure if mine stops beating yours won't
stop beating okay you know
our bodies are separated by material
world okay our minds our emotions we
touch each other but they're still
encapsulated the sense of existence is I
think of it as the only universal
constant interesting the sense of
existence knowing that we exist yes and
more it actually takes it to another
level knowing that we know we exist
yes visit arguable that a dog knows it
exists correct that's an interesting
question but a human what makes us
unique according to the Bible if you
think about you know the curse of
knowledge of good and evil
self-awareness eating the Apple that
story's all about that evolutionary step
into the ability to step back and
reflect on our own existence yeah that
ability is kind of what defines us as
humans apart from other animals that we
know of and that's a really great focus
for meditation because it's it's not
only constant amongst us
you know trans person it's also a
constant through time
so we're born with this sense of knowing
we exist even in the womb
at a certain point it goes it's the one
thing that we keep through our lives so
that can be a really powerful focus of
meditation
and since we're we had a song about
philosophy one of the philosophical
ideas in yoga is that this experience of
consciousness is actually universal and
what we're experiencing isn't generated
by our brains it rather our brains are
like an aerial picking up a constant
transmission that's omnipresent and they
collect parama Purusha or supreme
consciousness or Brahma means that which
is beyond understanding
so I'm Stein referred to it as a supreme
intelligence this idea that there is
that the basis of reality is not
actually matter it's actually
consciousness and all of reality is
arising out of that is a fundamental
precept of not only yoga philosophy a
lot of other philosophies
consciousness becomes embedded in the
matter then it starts with consciousness
the man that matter is actually
consciousness condensed that's like it's
very the dream it's a great metaphor
when you have a dream you create a world
within your mind yeah
the places and people that populate your
dream created from your mind stuff if
you like yes so you've created a
simulation in your dream and you don't
realize that you're a character in the
dream but you're also the one dreaming
it yes so how is this not that already
continuing well yeah so the idea you
know the concept of enlightenment is
actually that I wake up and I realized
that I am dreaming I am the one who's
dreaming the entire universe all of
reality and I hope I was all along but
that I is the same I that you were
experiencing there's only one I yes
which you know because they call Brahma
in the in the the yoga tradition yeah
that's okay okay Dada has got to come
back for round two because there's too
much cool stuff to unpack even in just
that little bit right there on
consciousness and also on the this
unifying print this unifying essence
that we have of being alive mmm that was
so cool so start with breath and then
feel being alive and realized that other
the other eight billion of us also feel
being alive that unifies us right yeah
so how do we you asked me for about what
I think is the highest emotion this idea
of universal love with there is no
barrier the I and you are the same this
is great Saint from India's name was
Ramana Maharishi and some one of his
disciples once catch over the last him
you know I've got this job and these
people I'm working when there's such a
pain they drive me crazy you know what I
do but what do I do about other people
and Robin and Myra she just said I'm not
aware of any other piece
he was in that state all the time
everything was was internal to him
interesting um and then it's kind of if
if one actually wants to assist
potentially in maybe eradicating some
poverty or some disease or advancing the
species in terms of our path towards
transhumanism and whatnot that it if one
wants to do that they kinda have to
activate a little bit of their ego but
in a more sane cultural dynamic so that
way one can actually innovate and create
as part of the collective fabric because
if one is constantly buzzing on that
feeling of there's no other this is all
one can one still innovate and create
simultaneously quite frictionlessly I
don't think anything in the world is in
reality is completely frictionless
because the universe is is a dualistic
version of oneness can it hurts it and
but I mean that's getting a little too
esoteric maybe but um the short answer
would be yes I there are there are
people doing amazing work out of very
very high selfless you could maybe
spiritual motivations yeah and they're
very effective you know I mean he's not
he's not um often cited in a sort of
spiritual context but I think Nelson
Nelson Mandela is a fantastic example of
somebody who transcended his
identification with a particular social
group and was ready to make tremendous
sacrifice in order to bring basically
prevent a terrible bloody civil war and
he's one of the one of the people who
really deserved his Nobel Peace Prize a
lot of people in my opinion didn't
really heard it but he sure did
and he's not and he spent 25 years in
prison he must have done a lot of
contemplation and soul-searching
but he he developed an incredible wisdom
through that and and I think he really
connected with his humanity in silence
in solitude and you know he never spoke
about meditation or spirituality or as
far as I know though he was close
friends with business with us but Bishop
tutu of course and he may have had some
private interest in me but he certainly
attained a level of selfless wisdom that
is evident from his remarkable life yes
yes that's that's a great example
there's the examples of selfless wisdom
are ones that more of us should prop up
as things that we teach children and
less so of the materialistic conspicuous
consumption garbage so okay this is as
OK as we're talking about meditation
because we we will need to have you back
for consciousness more there's too much
there but ok it within meditation I want
to I want us to touch on this we're
talking about the seed we're talking
about the trajectory of the seed when
applying meditation this is now
thousands of years old these lineages
transcend our little twenty-five fifty
year existence that were at so again
think thousands of years of practice
versus twenty five years hmm hmm you
know so these are the things like
humility okay humility so now when we
are able to scientifically prove as well
that your stress decreases your focus
increases your love and compassion
increases that we are now saying science
has now proven this as well so this is
why the minute
meditation recommendation comes in yeah
I I in my youth but ever there but in
the society you can say for between 12
and 19 I thought that human beings were
going to end the world through nuclear
war I had no interest in meditation or
spirituality or knowledge or information
about it big change in my life and the
thing that brought me was hope and I
thought wow there's a way that we can
change because it was clear to me that
human beings that this this dark side
has gained control is dominant and
that's reflecting in world affairs and
horrible wars and all this oppression
and exploitation but then I realized oh
my god there's a way that we can wake up
the good side of ourselves and that
anybody can do this and there are so
many examples through history even
people who've been very crooked and
corrupt and degenerate and transformed
you know the Silla de Saint sort of
stories that redemption stories which
people find particularly inspiring
because they think oh my god this hope
for me so that gave me hope and that's
really what inspired me to dedicate my
life to propagating the way that people
can change from within not that that's
all we need to do I think it's very
misleading to think that just doing
meditation is enough I think the hope
one of the main points of meditation is
that it wakes up this desire to help
other people mm-hmm and that not only i
but actually doing that actually going
out and serving and helping others is a
part of your practice giving brings some
in enhances your practice exactly and
what otherwise what's the point yeah I
had a student who in in Australia who
was had everything going from he was a
medical graduate he was just starting
his medical profession so he had a great
job at friends he's good looking 10
cents
everyone would think that he was a lucky
guy
he was always complaining to me about
how depressed he was and he was
meditating regularly and I finally lost
patience with him and I said look your
problem is you're always thinking about
yourself which is kind of blunt I don't
usually do that
I see when you go and help somebody else
for a change and get over yourself yeah
so I was uncharacteristically direct he
took me very seriously in two weeks
later he told me look I've just
committed to a six-month service project
in India I'm gonna go and work there as
a medical assistant for six months in a
poor village and he did it I was right
but he careful what I say yeah six
months later he came back and his face
had changed and I could see he had found
a real measure of peace and and he said
he said you know the thing I realized is
that I went there thinking I'm here's
the great white Savior going to help
these poor people and after a while I
realized I was the main beneficiary yeah
so meditation is not something that I
believe can is sufficient under itself
it's a part of a life that should be
very focused on service as well yes yes
and there's this interesting we get
30,000 days to live a third of those
you're gonna sleep you get about 20,000
waking days let's say out of those
20,000 waking days everyone gets to pick
what they want to do with their time now
when it comes to choosing one can give
to one's family in terms of time one can
give to one's community one can give
towards again an eradication of disease
or poverty across the world at large
scales these moonshot ideas so there's
all these varying scales and they're
different colors on a color wheel these
are not good or bad they're different
colors so give though is the is the
principle is carry this wake this aura
around you of positivity of give of love
and commence what the hands are for to
give
so gorgeous so much was built with this
everything yeah dolphins can't build
stuff you know they're smart they got
community they love each other
but if you tried you know building
something with flippers doesn't work oh
[Laughter]
goodness
okay all right so okay let's do um you
know since since we're you know you
actually since we're still on meditation
let's talk about this book and I can
grow uh-huh close your eyes and open
your mind which is also when I close my
eyes the song yeah yeah yeah we can't
tie together yes so anything well this
was not created in isolation incredible
contributions from a lot of other people
but I'm officially the author yeah
that's what everyone should read it is
my recommendation if you understand if
you want to understand the essence of
what I learned about meditation in well
in 30 years because I published this ten
years ago you have read the book but
there's no substitute for actually
practicing and experiencing meditation
yes yes you know it's like swimming you
can read lots of books about swimming
but if you were if you want to learn to
swim about to talk or get in the water
you know right theory is all very well
but you know practice is what makes it
happen so dolphins probably meditator
why do lots of piece so meditation let's
have a little little shot at it both do
it yeah so I want to show you a couple
of pictures first one of them is what
it's something I came up with recently
for a corporate I was teaching a group
at PayPal of PayPal managers
so they're very stressed and they're
they have to deal with some complicated
issues lots of numbers and so oh well
this is some of the research actually
I'll tell you a bit about this okay so
one of the things that's happening in
meditation is miserable and that is the
amount of the blood flow in the brain
which is what's being measured by an
fMRI scan that's a so functional
magnetic resonance imaging so it's its
it measures a cross-section it measures
the heat generated by blood flow and
what's being measured here is the heat
generated by the blood flow before
meditation it's kind of hot he just you
know it's it's been colorized so the
orange indicates heat the yellow a
lesser degree and blue it's typically
you know traditionally cooler ten
minutes of meditation from this same
brain to this brain meditators are cool
right if that speaks equanimity it means
your brain is literally cooled down what
does it mean in terms of your internal
experience it means not so many thoughts
mm-hmm
not so many overactive emotions this is
higher neural activity yep
higher neural activity higher in you
know and we experience that as thoughts
and the effect that this can happen so
quickly and there are you know tens of
thousands of these sorts of images yes
yes this is not one case of course there
and there are tens of thousands of
studies and each of those has thousands
of cases this happens when you meditate
the mind or the brain calls down
the frequency of thoughts reduces
anxiety reduces depression is one of the
reducing tendency to depression it's one
of the big outcomes and of course stress
so being as I say this has been you know
proven now as though 7,000 years of
subjective experience wasn't enough now
we need something supposedly objective
to convince us let's give the next image
so when you meditate what I tell people
doesn't quite fit on the screen but
Robert Ron Ron Ronnie's got it yeah I
asked them to close their eyes so I
asked you to close your eyes listen to
the mantra what you're going to do in a
minute so it's a Sanskrit phrase that
we're gonna sing and then you're I'm
gonna focus on that in the in the
meaning behind the mantra the music
fades you focus on the feeling of the
source of love within so you're kind of
moving through these that's perfect so
these these these sections and the
result is you feel mmm
okay your mind that your brain is slowed
down you feel more relaxed if you'll
calm and if you go deeply into it it can
feel really beautiful that's kind of
what's supposed to happen let's have a
look at what actually happens for a
beginner okay so you start off sit
straight close your eyes my brain hurts
at least I'm not thinking about work Dan
yeah oh no let's do four deadlines how
come deadlines sounds like a dead lion I
really love lions whether you are here
there were mantras about love thanks
lions
okay mantra I need you right now bar one
on cable um that's the mantra feeling
the love mmm okay that wasn't so hard I
feel kind of peaceful so that's for the
real experience with the mind wandering
the mind wandering yeah but you can
still meditate we're designed to be able
to meditate actually mm-hmm it's every
human can meditate pretty much so it's
it's just that it's not a perfect when
you first try it is you might like it to
be just like you you're not playing a
gorgeous song on the guitar the first
time you sit down with exactly for some
reason a lot of people have this Unreal
X and realistic expectation that when I
sit down and close my eyes I'm going to
be able to stop thinking this is a super
fantasy yes especially after you've
changed your mind 99.999% of the time to
be just shattering all the time the
months behind so when you exactly can't
just pick up the guitar it started
thinking three-pointers etc you can't
just go it takes time to process but
even during this process of gradually
training your your mind to slow down you
experience the benefits remarkably
quickly yeah
there's some neat there's a neat study
out of Harvard for some reason how
people's brains at Harvard's are special
you know at Harvard especial so Harvard
is they had a you know a control group
and a study group and they found it
German in less than two months of
regular meditation practice the
meditating group they actually could
measure the change in their brain
structure there was a court they called
cortical thickening
the frontal cortex actually thickened it
which indicates the development of
greater self-awareness interesting and
it happened that quickly the prefrontal
cortex that thickens it as miserable
whoa the first thing this kind of very
there's a lot of brain changes
measurable rain changes but usually
you'd think that would take a lot longer
but only two months yeah yeah of regular
practice yeah very very interesting and
a greater amount of self-awareness than
with that executive function yeah yeah a
little bit less of an inclination to
want to potentially get dinged and
and/or commit some sort of an active
of harm yes of greater capacity to
reflect and pause before you know
reacting in perhaps a necklace yes the
past the pause is so beautiful
they have a whole pause thing at Google
now which is part of their meditation
program I love it yeah I love it
yeah the pauses is key it's a huge key
in in life not doing stupid stuff yeah
yeah yeah um this is this is good this
is a nice wander into yeah into the
science as well as into the actual
experience and yeah let's try to do it
yes so next image please and we're gonna
sing this little mantra here so one of
the methods in access Sanskrit that is
Sanskrit baba nam kevalam you can't
along he cave on a table ah yeah baba
nam kevalam baba nam kevalam yep we
leave a feeling of limitless so the idea
here is that we're going to focus on the
source of love inside ourselves so he
only takes a moment thought to observe
that you know all the love we've ever
experienced comes from inside of
ourselves so I want to be in that place
mm-hmm so the idea is that the you know
there is this part of ourselves that
generates this feeling and we're
connecting to that and that it doesn't
have any limit we know we're not going
to put any boundary on that so we're
connecting to this source of limitless
love within ourselves all right I'm
going to sing the mantra for a minute
and we're going to guide you into a very
short super short meditation on baba nam
kevalam and this mantra right
so just close your eyes and sit straight
and if you're watching this which I hope
you are yes it's right make yourself
comfortable
feet flat on the floor maybe or you
might have a little meditation room of
your own if you were lucky and I close
your eyes
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
just keep your eyes closed
and remember to sit straight
and breathe through your nose if you can
comfortably and keep your hands in your
lap
and let the mantra baba nam kevalam with
the music continue in your mind as
though you are hearing it played back to
you by the voice of your memory you're
just observing you're listening and it's
playing on automatically
and if your mind wanders don't worry
that's perfectly natural but when you
notice that just bring your attention
back to the mantra and the music
and begin to feel that this mantra is
coming from a place deep within you as
though your inner self were singing to
you
and drawing your attention to this place
within you where the love comes from
you're connecting to the source of this
feeling of love within yourself
and as you come deeper into it you
realize that it has no boundary
there are no limits
to the potential
of the love within you
to flip the mantra and the music
continue in your mind and it's drawing
your attention inward to this source of
limitless love
you just focus on that in silence for a
moment
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
just take a deep breath
did you breathe out you can relax
and you can open your eyes
so you can practice that at home every
day twice a day I'll give you a link
later where people can actually find a
download of a guided meditation like
that's free and that link will be in the
bio that yeah
go
so it's you know that was really short
normally you know people meditate for a
bit longer than that but you know we're
on TV
but uh it's amazing the difference it
can make to how you feel not just during
meditation and for the few minutes
afterwards but it kind of creeps into
your day and so you find that you know
you experience this I know you meditate
it changes the way that you feel in a
subtle way all the time
and again on just the scales of things
it can even be as simple as just
taking control of the monkey mind
chattering and just taking a mindful
deep breath with eyes closed for a
moment and then that can even change the
physiology then and further next as a
butterfly effect for the next couple
moments so it can even be just a single
mindful connection to the breath and to
that love you know as you were mm-hmm as
you were delivering Bob
okay as you were delivering it and you
were talking about the feeling that love
inside
very profound
check out the link in the bio everyone
and again give it give tap in tap in
word check in with yourself at least
once a day twice a day just check in in
word it's so important so important okay
i we have we have obviously so much more
to talk about so let's uh Ronnie are you
okay with going a tad bit longer not not
too much but just a little
just a little bit I don't care all right
let's go a little thanks ready thanks
Ronnie as you as you can see the
preferred technical director of the Bay
Area you see what he did there when the
image was too big he no got my job doing
it do it at all you know yeah
doing it all handling the the other
other mic and not and the instrument
doing really good with the PTC's on the
zooms on the instruments and switches
he's he's you see him well stop wasting
time talking about me and get back to
the show all right all right back to the
show
so that was picked up in India mm-hmm
okay yeah and this has been a mantra for
a long time this is actually a new
mantra this is a new mantra yes
interesting most of the mantras that
you'll hear people singing or using in
meditation well you know maybe in silent
meditation they'll be using most of them
are very old some of them they're I mean
I know mantras that literally come from
the 7000 years ago yes this mantra is
from the 1970s very cool I like new neat
neologism it's got kind of new energy
new energy interesting yeah the theory
the theory that I know is and I've had
some experiences that seem to support
this I'm a real spiritual mantra that's
designed for meditation is kind of
empowered by somebody who has who knows
how to do that I mean somebody you could
say a great spiritual guru they can kind
of magnetize it's kind of like
magnetizing steel or something and it
increases its effect but that fades over
very very long period of time so a new
mantra that's been empowered in that way
actually has a stronger impact than the
older mantras that have great lost some
degree of their their magnetic whatever
it is it's not really magnetic but I'm
using it
yeah
interesting and that's this is also a
big what I think an indication to the
power of the neologisms is the power of
changing up the nomenclature to new
thought-provoking words and mantras that
can potentially awaken the newer
generations and Millennials that Gen see
who's coming next so okay
okay so this is on a version of 1a 101
of of meditation yeah this is super baby
step yeah super baby style they're up
even baby as tapes but yeah this is yes
yes yes because you know you reference
this earlier that there's you know being
on stage with 10000 people is a certain
kind of feeling of great feeling an
ecstatic feeling but one can actually
interestingly enough in complete silence
achieve even greater of a feeling
themselves with inward practice and that
is very profound to think because
there's so much cultural paradigm and
code that is pushing towards the
material will make you ecstatic the fame
will make you ecstatic
all of those things will make you
ecstatic and so it's very cool to to go
counterculture and go in okay we talked
a bit on the on the neuroscience side of
things on the physiology side of things
and and that was varied those very very
important on the creativity side of
things you know you wrote another book
as well and this is a lot of what you
speak about as well when you go and
speak as you speak about these
principles of meditation creativity
enlightened leadership mmm-hmm when you
speak and let's hit those last two on
creativity and enlightened leadership a
lot of this is coming from the heart the
emotional intelligence the ethics and
the morals take precedence we're talking
about how to how to behave in a you know
political setting potentially in a
business setting so yeah teach us about
this Romo stirs sure there's we've
talked about research being a lot of
research into meditation one of the big
outcomes is it helps manage stress
anxiety and a lot of negatives the other
thing that it does is give you a whole
lot of positives which more difficult to
measure often one of them is creativity
there's a really neat study out of
Holland out of Leyden University where
they found that yes certain types of
meditation enhance the creativity idea
generation there are different ways of
doing this and I teach actually a range
of methods of tapping into creativity
creativity and sort of sparking it but
the one that I call the long game is the
meditation practice there are little
tricks you can do exercises that will
definitely help you to be more in your
kind of child mode children are more
imaginative than adults by a huge factor
you can get part of that back by going
through visualizations and things but
all of those are like what I call quick
fixes they don't grow your ability to
tap into that over time they're just
something you can do in the moment and
get into a creative mood or you know
they're more likely to come up with a
good idea but meditating over time
actually grows your ability to be more
creative and that's why I've considered
the most powerful tool in you know poke
it's sort of arrow in the quiver I think
so when I poke yes to which is very cool
creativity and focused yes
improves focus improves of course
there's bunch of positive outcomes
thinks have a quick look at those can we
see the next image please so one of the
things I do with companies they what
they want outcomes better one here about
consciousness or any of this wishy-washy
stuff it's a way to you know soft an
unmeasurable flame but actually you
interviewed Andrew yang yes and I wash
they're going to be fascinating and you
know he's got amazing ideas and he's
obviously super switched on about the
dramatic change in the nature of work
that's upon us as a result of course
automation and AI so that's something I
actually speak about as well
have been for a couple of years so I'm
it's not my field but I read about it
and I'm an amateur but I'm I do know
quite a bit about the mind and our sort
of undeveloped capabilities and so what
I speak about to companies is the kind
of capabilities and skills that will
come as a kind of side effect of
meditation and this is a little yes
picture of future proof of skills this
of course speaks to you know the the
point that Andrew yang is making and
many others that a lot of the sort of
work we've been doing is going away how
do we remain relevant how do we you know
what kind of things should be focusing
on if we want to remain employable at
the sort of base level interesting and
useful at a higher level
yes interested in life yeah at an even
higher level so of course the the great
term alibaba fellow what's his
I'm a jack man he spoke about this at
the Davos hundreds something he heard he
was focusing on education and you know
he loved because that's actually his own
background yeah he wasn't a businessman
he was a teacher and he's gone back into
that now
he's more because he finds it more
fulfilling and after making his billions
here are some of the skills that you can
develop through meditation that people
don't really expect so emotional
intelligence a big one and that's
actually the main thing that attracted
so many Google employees to the Google
program search inside yourself hmm
because you've got all these brilliant
yeah the search inside yourself it's a
very it's a very popular program at
Google and you know the way that they
finally in a maintain one of the
co-founder of that program he said that
the the breakthrough point came when
they started promoting it as emotional
intelligence and then all the you know
these super super smart engineers who
don't have very high emotional
intelligence typically we're saved no
they thought I need that and thousands
of them took this program so that's a
big one
integrity against comes from
self-awareness you know meditation kind
of subtly pushes you to being more
honest with yourself oh yeah it can be a
little uncomfortable
they help you have to go through that
process to grow to being flexible and
that again comes from being if you're
more identifying with this core of
self-awareness you're less dependent on
circumstances so you're more flexible
because you've got this kind of core
that can look in any direction positive
attitude you know it stimulates positive
emotions and a positive more sort of
positive perspective creativity is
because the one that I focus on because
that's my kind of pet topic decision
making your mind's clearer you're more
focused less bothered by anxiety and
emotions and bias yes develops intuition
leadership qualities that the other big
theme I focus
your communication because you let's
scare the people and afraid what they
think of you you yeah and your list you
know you're listening to them rather
than the voice in your head yeah yeah oh
that's that's it's basic but super
important teamwork of course is related
to a lot of these that are EQ equals
better teamwork right so these of course
all influence one another so these are
just a little list I made a future-proof
soft skills along to convince companies
they should invest time and resources in
helping their employees to develop these
so that they don't become irrelevant as
they're some of the workers taken over
by an automation creativity thing this
is my pit subject because I'm a musician
and I write songs and I write stories
and there's so I have a sensible book
you've seen this in about meditation
this is totally self-indulgent this is
my silly book it's called real dragons
don't cry and it's a fantasy story it's
the first of a series of five books the
chronology is one of the official terms
mm-hmm it's a it's a fantasy novel about
a vegetarian dragon and it's a long
story just kind of by indulgent you know
acting out of my childhood fantasy of
being a fantasy writer yes yes yes but
the it took me a long time to get to
this because I was you know Lord of the
Rings was my first religion when I was a
kid I realized that I took a great deal
of my moral guidance from from Gandalf
well this is long before the film's but
yeah New Zealand is Melissa yeah we've
claimed it so I bet so I always wanted
to write a fantasy story but I was
always afraid of you know writing a
cheap imitation a poor imitation of
Tolkien because nobody you know
thousands have tried and all failed so I
thought I can't do that I can't I don't
want to you know
be imitating what he did and then I
finally realized later I was actually
writing some scripts for some stand-up
comedian friends of mine and I and I had
a comedy blog and I realized oh
talking's not funny there's only two
jokes in Lord of the Rings and neither
of them are funny so I thought okay I
can I can write a comedy fantasy story
and I started doing because they might
won't be compared to talking which is
and I don't want to be because he's bit
better than I'll ever bring the bait so
anyway he's creative thinking yes yes
well the the whole you Vivian Ming
another one of our really just awesome
thought leaders on maximizing human
potential and also robot proofing kids
oh nine eating robot poop skill sets
right this is this is what that is I
love it
and it's such a such a crucial part of
our future
as we enter the AI on automation age
passing the torch to non-biological
intelligence let's let's do this sincere
self work this inner management tuning
in word practice so we can better pass
the torch more more effectively and you
know one of the points there was also
leadership right and this enlightened
leadership that comes from the heart
that is emotionally intelligent that
realizes that maximizing the potential
of every single seed to its fullest in
the world is a massive creative priority
for everyone
an immoral priority yeah and one of the
reasons I focus on leadership is because
people in positions of leadership
obviously it's a point of leverage they
have a lot of influence what they do the
effect of what of the decisions they
make is is amplified because they have
power but I also emphasize that you know
we shouldn't think that the only leaders
are people who've got big public
positions everybody in some way is a
leader we influence people you influence
people for your channel you influence
your friends you influence your family
if you have children you influence your
children I was a the youngest of four
kids but at least I was the leader of my
dog I could boss my dog so so the point
here is to really help people to develop
the attitude and the perspective that
will make you a benevolent leader yes
and that ripple effect that you have and
depending on the number of people you
are influencing that will be a good
effect yes and you know I don't see any
perfect leaders around but I see some
who are trying and some who don't seem
to be interested in trying to be
belittled and I would always encourage
you know those everybody or anyone with
a position of trust to exercise their
power with a view of you know the
greatest good for the greatest number of
people
for the greatest possible period of time
and fuller dog wisdom okay
this bit quite is okay I did it to five
different there you go so interesting so
so the scale of leadership again it's
it's it's with yourself it's with your
family with your community with the
world on the largest scales of influence
as well the benevolent leadership and
the inner self work that happens to help
us become a more benevolent leader okay
I know we could just keep going and we
let's let's let's wrap um two quick
questions on the way out
are we in a simulation I don't think so
well it depends what you mean by
simulation if you mean a technological
one then no identity
but I might be the agent of the
artificial intelligence that's
programmed to convince you that you're
not in the simulation so you know thanks
for saying they'd appreciate it I favor
molecules over electrons in this debate
I'm I think yeah I like you know what
buddy we can say Cavanagh a silicon okay
yeah yeah I'm I think we need to get
back to our human absolutely any more to
you know the one thing what a lot more
work that needs to be done pre pre baton
pass oh yeah yeah yeah and and we're
we're much better there are things that
we are much better at then even the
smartest artificial intelligence like
we're much better at knowing we exist
for example you know yeah we're really
good at that and they're incredibly bad
at so we should get this sort of
inferiority complex because we have
young wonderful powers that we should be
using in the best way it would be very
interesting to see what a super
intelligence would feel or process when
it's plugged into Gaia when it's plugged
into the the oneness that one
consciousness that would be cool but I
don't know if it's possible well yeah
that's a good point
yeah let's see it lets see about that
it's a good point okay and last question
what is the most beautiful thing in the
world
the moment of awakening when somebody
realizes that they can change
and become somebody extraordinary
oh yeah
yeah yeah that's really good that's
really good Oh to catalyze more of those
is paramount I love it I love it
I don't think we've had that as an
answer yet which is great I've never
given it before thank you this has been
so wonderful thought I think you think
you think you thank you you're fun to
talk with yes sir you mind Disick
California try it every day for one year
a patient man he is also colorful that
the two colors have been mixing very
interestingly and you as well on the
great colorful mind okay round two will
have to happen we look forward to round
two more meditation more guitar more
about 30 more songs that were for her
perfect then those actually there's a
way and those songs are also available
on iTunes technology you know it's good
it's come on these little dots on it you
can't see pretty cool this is
high-quality this is high-quality
reproduction unlike your mp3s yeah yeah
see the whole thing with with being
right here next to the guitar was
extremely powerful with that with with
all the the essence versus hearing
envious stereo now this is all available
on the monk do calm you have links for
these you also have the links to onto
iTunes this is available on iTunes as
well the mp3 for I mean mp3 for my but
until we can clone you and ship you
around the world to sing baba nam
kevalam and then in addition to this we
have you know the books as well are
available so do check that out as well
the monk do calm links in the bio go and
check that out also subscribe to Dada on
YouTube Dada has a bunch of great
content on YouTube go and check that out
the link again is below in the bio and
thank you thank you everyone
for tuning in we are so appreciative of
you thank you and give us your thoughts
in the comments below we'd love to hear
from you about your thoughts on this
episode let us know what you're thinking
let us know how the practice is going
talk about it we have our simulation
chat let's get more people talking about
it going do it yourself talk to your
parents your friends your community on
social media get talking about
meditation and what it's doing for you
start spreading it watering those seeds
with meditation around the world huge
thank you and shout out to Ron Vargas
our producer and director we love you so
much thank you thank you thank you for
these great cuts this episode and for
handling the extra time we really
appreciate it thank you thank you and go
and build everyone go and build manifest
your dreams into the world support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in help catalyze their growth
around the world our links are below as
well to help us grow a simulation build
create execute we love you so much thank
you for tuning in we will see you soon
everyone peace
[Applause]
[Music]